c'est un projet architectural culturel
social et qui divise l'amérique barack
obama défend la construction d'une
mosquée à ground zero à quelques mètres
des attentats du 11 septembre 2001
contre le world trade center
neuf ans après la tragédie un vif débat
sur la nature de l'islam agite de
nouveau l'opinion publique américaine
bernard lebras la mosquée de la discorde
dans les rangs des manifestants des
néoconservateurs et autres militants
républicains mais aussi de simples new
yorkais qui considère ce projet comme
une insulte aux victimes des attentats
du 11 septembre il ya quelques jours
dans cet immeuble municipal la ville de
new york dont le maire conservateur et
michael bloomberg a donné son feu vert à
ce projet de construction hier soir à
washington
participant à un dîner de rupture du
jeûne du ramadan le président démocrate
des états unis a pris position en tant
que ça joyent 1 en tant que président je
crois que les musulmans ont le même
droit de pratiquer leur religion que
quiconque dans ce pays
cela inclut le droit de construire un
lieu de culte et un centre communautaire
dans une propriété privée au sud de
manhattan dans les limites et le respect
des lois
c'est ça l'amérique
à new york le nouveau centre culturel
islamique serait construite ici même à
la place de cet immeuble il se trouve à
200 mètres de ground zero à vol d'oiseau
soit à deux blocs d'immeubles au numéro
45 de parts presse voulue comme un
centre de dialogue entre les religions
par ses promoteurs ce centre culturel
islamique devrait être inauguré l'an
prochain en 2011 année du 10e
anniversaire des attentats du 11
septembre
com